when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you
could could do more
but i guess
we are doing some
insane amount of work so
i hope we we got to be
ready enough
[Music]
i just feel like he's been more focused
i know that they're always focused but
it feels like he's really zoned in on
this game compared to game one
this type of position definitely offers
black huge winning chances yeah i think
jan is the one who should be more
disappointed about this result because
he had objective chances while magnus
looked promising in the opening but i
don't know if he was ever objectively
better
this is awesome i mean this this showing
maybe so far the best showing of opening
prep from beyond in the match
his preparation really held up and that
will make
yon try to search for something that he
can that he can put pressure on magnus
in the remaining games
[Music]
the world champion has never lost on his
birthday but will he get the w as we
move into day four of the feed a world
chess championship
[Music]
he can make the draw whenever he wants
yeah i'd have six check 98 check the
king will go up to g7 back in g8 so he
has that drawn his pocket and this is a
smart thing to do
[Music]
the first time we have an italian right
now we're looking like we're headed down
a road of bobby was right again
it felt like that opportunity for yon
that you do not get very often because
when magnus is well prepared and in
position that he feels comfortable in
good luck beating him today felt like
that opportunity and jan let us slip by
[Music]
your general feeling about the result
given the position that you had
and the potential opportunities that you
have oh of course i'm disappointed
it's game six it's day six for the 2021
feed a world chess championship what
will the world champion do with his
third chance with the white pieces
he's not recalling he's he's studying
he's studying i like that and that's
important because
magnus caught him off guard he's trying
to figure out this position and just
because he didn't take the pawn and he
didn't develop doesn't mean that the
rest of the game is easy for him like
from the way he's acting
his body language and the fact that he
was playing very rapidly and now he's
stopping to think
it looks like 96 was a bit of a surprise
but i don't understand how it can be a
surprise
i don't know the way he's played this
game so far this really has been the
most impressive game jan has played
[Music]
magnus moves the queen up
game on ladies and gentlemen we have
action in game six not bishop before
what did they have in mind it was
fishing before was such an intentional
move i'm like
i'm kind of puzzled jan is trying to
keep this confusing for magnus with
these moves wait what just happened
nicely fine no this is this could be
true dawn is blowing this position here
with no time now well like queen before
look 94 because if you take the knight
you lose the bishop magnus carlsen has
reached time control jan napomishi has
one more move to make or he loses on
time
queen b3
oh my gosh
[Music]
beyond is defending this end game
defending is saying him incredibly well
i i think that this is frankly if john
holds this it might be as telling in
regards to what we'll be talking about
in the world championships anything else
because this is the test
we have broken history here in the 2021
world chess championship because the
move rook to d2
officially makes this game
the longest game in world chess
championship history
[Music]
black has to be careful this is going to
be so hard for yon to hold because this
is he's just going to keep pushing this
[Music]
i think that's just winning because you
can't you can no longer check that king
anymore
[Music]
i expect yonda panmashi
to throw in the towel in this position
that's the way it is as i said it
shouldn't be easy in a world
championship match you have to
to try for every
every chance no matter how how small it
is
[Music]
i do like this initial position from
jan's point of view we see that magnus
is the one who's going to the think tank
first and jan has not had a problem
getting nice positions out of the
opening this is critical he needs to be
able to convert on his advantage doesn't
mean just win right but
you can't just allow max to make an easy
equalization of a worse position
john missed a slight chance to maybe
keep pressing with knight takes c4
bobby actually was predicting this exact
opening and what what made you think
that he would be
because it's what i would do
whoa
so wait queen a3
probably i didn't defend in the best way
but uh
it becomes really unpleasant and i guess
uh
frankly speaking it's it's hard to
defend after such such a bond
[Music]
it is game nine for the 2021 fiat world
chess championship fabiano caruana just
put a big smile on his face he is
excited about the game we're going to
get today i will tell you that
[Music]
it's a difficult position i think at
least jan is keeping a significant edge
on the clock that's a big thing
it's losing weight it's losing oh my god
did he just blow he did c6 oh my god oh
my goodness and magnus is scowling
because i think he sees it
i i'm i'm blown away
by this blunder
absurd
could you clarify why you use this word
than any other
it's just because you don't uh
you don't expect to
um basically win a piece for for nothing
um
at this level so
there's no way he can put the petrol
here because yeah yeah you can play as
queen e2 trade queens and there's no way
there's there's a million ways to make a
drone on petrol
uh well uh it was necessary first of all
first and foremost to play a normal game
like
without
i know blunders
i very much assume he's gonna
he's gonna try and win
especially with the white pieces
[Music]
magnus carlsen is on the brink of adding
five time to his world chess
championship resume will today be the
day or does the challenger keep us here
just a little bit longer and maybe start
the comeback story we're looking for he
played g3 oh my gosh
this is magnus at his best and in a very
difficult task
for yon de palma she is the challenger
the dominating storyline right now is
blunder after blunder and it just feels
like it was gift wrapped to magnus this
is just unbelievable
[Music]
[Applause]
you